[Music]
i could get more jacks though i can't
improve i can't change my face
i agree with that that's that's what
i've picked yeah not a big face because
i could i can
i'm content with my face so
what do you think so when you're trying
to hook up with a girl what's the
hardest thing
for me like like what what gets this
um what the hell what is the hardest
thing
what's
me and jess what's the worst objection
that you get like the most common one
from girls probably that they don't
believe that i'd be a fateful guy
i could see that
i mean i did come in here said i have
girl friends to be fair i think it's
based off of the words you say oh okay
to be fair like i think you say things
that imply you couldn't be a faithful
guy so like if you're saying
yeah i can't be a faithful guy
[Laughter]
and then they're like they're like you
know what i'm not a detective but i
don't think you could be a faithful guy
it's like are they
definitely said that
marriage is the ultimate goal and i'd be
a one-woman man
so yeah but that was after you like
looked with like pain in your eyes and
thought of sleeping with one girl
and also and also said i have multiple
girls they're friends though
no no hate you know don't have the
player hate the game like i feel like if
girls are offering [ __ ] on demand like
why would you not take it i get that
okay based on like the things you say
you know well
i feel like i i struggle before i even
say certain things so uh-huh yeah
they just seem to feel like i will be a
cheater for whatever reason i could see
the reason okay
but see you say i can see the reason and
then you say that is my words so do you
see it or is it based on what oh sorry
i'm sorry i could hear the reason you
can hate it right yeah okay like based
on that
i can accept that more than i can see
the reason oh okay yes
sorry i'm i meant yeah
so that's your biggest biggest objection
you're like baby come home with me i
don't know how the guys do the game you
know or maybe like maybe you're out
she's at your place she's like you know
what
but girls love cheaters that should help
you get into bed well
i feel the problem is is when i actually
want to be serious um
you know i mean if i love being serious
with cheaters you you're not getting
cheated on you would think so right they
do listen to her on the couch but maybe
the fear is oh
i had never cheated no not you
the girls yeah yeah
maybe maybe the fear is that i'm i'm
actually not going to cheat therefore
they're not gonna get to enjoy the
toxicness of a relationship um
so you think they think you're too
stable and really they say
that you're gonna cheat but it's like a
[ __ ] test and really they're like he
wouldn't cheat you wouldn't cheat so it
would probably get boring
what about you ash what's the biggest
what's the biggest objection that you
get with the females the ladies
the biggest objection i get with the
ladies yeah
four
um
communication
you don't communicate yeah
you like ghost them
but like if you like the girl then you
communicate with her now yeah so then
you just like the complaint would be
like
you don't like them no i no
i i just i tend to ghost from time to
time but it's just because i get busy
but then but if you liked them you
wouldn't ghost right it's just like you
didn't like it i'm just i'm i'm not
you're not meeting like a girl your
dreams and like ghosting her of course
you're busy no
you're not that busy
i mean you could like you could send a
text during the show it's just like not
i'm not there yet you can definitely
make it i'm not gonna do hey you say
this but right now if i put you i see
you chatting with guests you could like
pull for a second you know text her hey
guys right now put my purpose first
you feel me
yo
check the
[Music]
there's nothing there
a purpose first
yeah that's what i'm on can i read this
next super chat yeah i got a seductive
voice reuben i don't know if you wanted
me or pro read it but i'ma read it
ruben ruben rubin
i just wrote that so you can say my name
my life is complete now
keep up the good work and i hope to see
you in a new venue soon watching from
orlando florida
okay someone needs to pay her to do
was it asmr asmr asmr
would you guys watch it if i did it
of course they would put a w in the chat
if you would watch jess we'll get you
set up put a drooling emoji we'll get
you
hi guys
welcome back to my channel
it's that time
[Music]
welcome back to just prolly things
what's the best pick-up line you guys
got that like works the best like if
you're gonna cold-approach a girl on the
street what would you say
oh
i wanna see if you'd work on me okay
wait i'm gonna i'm gonna pretend i would
be like ha ha ha ha pretend walking down
this minute oh man
like okay so i wouldn't use it but i
mean okay i could say it to you okay
yeah so like do you believe in what do
you believe in love at first sight
or should i walk by again
asmr
that's clever that's clever
what about you um
see you wait would you just say that if
i was walking
like like that's how you'd approach a
girl no
how would you approach her if i was
approaching a girl yeah
i'd just say hello
and if she says hello back i'll start
talking
okay where are you
pick-up line yeah i ain't done this in a
minute
have i ever got one
oh gosh um
um
pick up online pick online pick offline
help me
i got one you know
come back to me
we gotta work on that yeah i know oh
what about you blessing you got a pickup
line
i don't have a mic
he didn't make
he said i'm legally blind
i'm about to be legally sleep here
you can take a nap i'm feeling good no
i'm feeling good you can give me
tomorrow no no i'm gonna okay you sure
i'm impossible i was like i need you to
take a nap so i can do it
no that makes sense
i don't got any pick-up lines i don't
think
the only one i can think of is when my
brother told me but it was more to be
funny i don't think i'd use it
it's like not good oh it's like baby did
you fart because you blew me away
[Laughter]
that's that's what i said i was like my
brother i just thought it was
did funny hurt pearl
when i fell from here